The first day of summer
is June 21st,
and TSA officials are predicting
record-breaking travel.
While most people plan to --
-Ahh.
-Aah! I'm so sorry. this is one
of my writers, Lutz.
Lutz, what are you doing?
-I'm relaxing after a long day
at working here at "Late Night."
I invited you to join me.
Didn't you get the invite?
-What invite?
-Check your phone.
-I don't have my phone
on me right now.
-Weird.
Wally, you got the invite,
right?
-You bet your sweet bippy,
I did.
[ Laughter ]
-"You bet your sweet bippy"?
-Seth, it's what all the
cool kids are saying.
-Come on, Seth, let's have a
Heineken. It's after work.
-It is most definitely
not after work.
We just started the show.
-We did?
-Yeah?
Do you not see the audience?
-Yeah, but I thought
Wally just invited
all of them to hang, too.
-You thought Wally
invited an entire audience to
have a beer with just you guys?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, hey, hey! It seems like
they wanted to do it, yes! Whoo!
-Please, I'm begging
you, don't cheer for him.
-Aw, Seth, come on. I'm just
trying to help you out.
When you schedule time to block
your calendar after work
with up to three friends,
Heineken may send you some
beer money via Venmo towards
your first round.
That way, you can combat
endless summer meetings
and open some
work life-balance on them.
-That does sound pretty good.
-You bet your sweet bippy.
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
But maybe we could do this whole
thing after the show.
-Or how about
at the commercial break?
-Alright, fine.
visit Heineken.com/closer
for beer money via Venmo,
plus other surprises for you and
your friends this summer.
-And be cool like me.
Wink.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And me. Wink.
-You guys don't need --
I keep telling you,
you don't need to say "wink"
if you actually wink.
-Oh.
[ Light laughter ]
-We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."
[ Cheers and applause ]